a CBS News investigation reveals a
growing trend at health clinics
nationwide that could be putting
patients at risk clinics are selling
hormone therapy treatment some believe
provides a Fountain of Youth but as dr.
Jon LaPook shows us there are people
people are finding out about the dangers
of some clinics the hard way
I was afraid I was going to die two
years ago federal corrections officer
Emmett Landry was taken to a Houston
Texas hospital after having a stroke at
age 41 I was I was afraid I wasn't going
to see my kids again my family about a
month earlier Landry had been feeling
fatigued when co-workers told him about
optimum wellness a clinic in Nederland
Texas that could treat him with hormones
yeah I was just looking for something to
help me get through the day at the
hospital doctors tried to figure out why
someone so young would have a stroke the
only thing that they could deduce and
think of is that the testosterone had to
have caused a clotting a nurse
practitioner at the clinic had
prescribed Landry testosterone even
though his testosterone blood levels
were normal with rare exceptions The
Endocrine Society recommends against
testosterone therapy in patients with
normal testosterone levels it's almost
like a scam how so they're gonna tell
you that your something is wrong with
you and then the more people they can
get filtered in lined up like cattle and
then it's more money for them gain new
energy and how our investigation found
there are clinics across the country
prescribing hormones like testosterone
to people with normal blood levels
Landry says his nurse practitioner only
highlighted the benefits he didn't say
that there's possible risk of heart
disease no sir
stroke no sir no problems whatsoever
we're discussed no sir in Texas
nurse practitioners are not allowed to
prescribe hormones without a doctor's
approval
Landry's treatment was overseen by dr.
James Kern an OBGYN in Houston about a
hundred miles away excuse me dr. Kern
I'm from CBS News would you be able to
please tell me why Emmitt Landry was
prescribed testosterone when he had
normal blood hormone levels in 2017 the
optimum clinic was raided by the DEA
shortly after that Kern withdrew his
supervision
the DEA declined to comment that was
furious Amy Townsend is a doctor in
Southeast Texas I'm seeing is multiple
people that are my friends and my family
that are being treated completely
inappropriately she decided to report
the clinic to the state nursing board I
felt that it was something that needed
to be done to protect the community and
did they take actions oversight comes
from state medical and nursing boards
CBS News reached out to both sets of
boards in all 50 states of the 95
percent that responded only seven states
have both medical and nursing boards who
keep track of incidents related to
hormone therapy right now this practice
of giving testosterone to people who in
your mind shouldn't be getting it it's
still going on it's widespread
throughout the country they're preying
on the fears of everybody growing older
how are you feeling when you walked out
of the hospital embarrassed what were
you embarrassed about that I went to
these physicians looking for help I had
a stroke
and I'm supposed to be taking care of my
family in February 2018 the nurse
practitioner who treated Landry lost his
license for inappropriately prescribing
hormones to Landry and others and in
August the clinic closed its doors for
good people have been looking for the
Fountain of Youth for a long time
they're not gonna find it they're not
gonna find it at their corner store
clinic Landry is now suing dr. Kern and
the nurse practitioner who treated him
at the clinic they've denied Landry's
allegations we reached out to dr. Kern
and the nurse practitioner but they
declined our request for comment talking
yes there is no such thing as the
Fountain of Youth unfortunately we all
want it we're all we love it but not so
far no all right dr. Jon LaPook thank
you very much